when you first moved to los angeles and
started working
whether it was a little side job or in
the industry
did you work any jobs for free were you
willing to take
unpaid work so yes i did
lots of pro bono work and just to get
experience or
um you know that kind of stuff again
you have to do it to a degree because of
course you still have to make sure
you're doing something to earn you know
some kind of income to
pay rent and get some food and all of
that
but yeah there was plenty of times and i
did it for years not
every time but something would come up
like hey this is a
unpaid gig but we ne we could use some
help or you know anytime i had the
opportunity
once i got a little bit of stability
with work
i would still do those i don't do it as
much anymore just because i
don't have the time but if those windows
of time do open up i
you know never have an issue with
volunteering some time
to help somebody out but yeah in the
beginning there was
a bunch of credit building stuff that i
was willing to do
because again i would view it as a like
like i said an education
i knew i was going to learn something
and i knew i was going to meet some new
people
and those two things are incredibly
valuable especially in this business
you hear all the time it's who you know
that's 100
true that is what this business is it is
who you know it's the relationships you
build it's not
necessarily the oh somebody's giving
favoritism or whatever i'm sure those
things happen too
but it is about if you came and
volunteered on somebody shoot
you did a great job helping them with
whatever it was
when they have a paid job they're going
to call you too you know what i mean
and that's that's how it works and
and those friendships and those and even
just business relationships
have almost always led to a paying job
in some
way shape or form um and
i tell people all the time when they're
asking about getting into this business
like what's the
what's the best thing i could do i said
create something just create doesn't
even matter what it is
put some energy into it put some
creative energy and create something
because
you're going to call some friends and
see if they're available they're going
to ask some people whatever
however that's going to work and you're
going to create something now you can
show people something you've created
and at the same time you've now
strengthened some relationships or maybe
met some new people
and that network starts building up of
who you know
and and they now know what you do and
you know it
kind of goes from there i've had people
who i hadn't worked with in six years
call me up for a job
because whatever impression i made way
back then
it somehow came around and i came up or
they saw me on social media posting
something and
here's my new you know short film on
youtube and they go
i remember him i worked with him on you
know and so it's all about that it's all
about relationship building so
um doing the free jobs to me
it it's always
beneficial if you have the means to do
it obviously
don't put yourself out on the street
because you're taking 20 free jobs and
you have no way to pay your bills but
within reason i say do it because you're
going to gain experience and you're also
going to gain
relationships of those times that you
worked for free
for credit for something on your wheel
whatever how much of that actually led
to paid work
down the line i think that that quite a
few of them did and again
i think it has to do with how much
energy you're willing to put into
something
i never approached a free job as like ah
it's a free job i'm going to have
you know half ass this job i always
approached it is i'm going to do
the best i can do work as hard as i can
to help the project be successful
and i think because of that mindset and
attitude
i made enough an impression on people
that
that they wanted to hire me for when
they got the pain gig or whatever
you know what i mean so i think again
i think almost every one of those jobs i
met and
and created a friendship or or working
relationship with
at least a few people on each one of
those sets that then led to me getting
called
for something else even if it was low
paying you know hey
can you help out with this you know i
enjoyed working with you on that
can you uh you know i'm really trying to
think of any of that that
led kind of that never got a phone call
that way
but um
[Music]
i just i can't really think of one that
didn't i think they all kind of led in
some way sometimes it wasn't right away
like i said
but they eventually
almost all of them led to something
positive in that way
and again it's i think just
chalking it up to to hard work not being
afraid of hard work
you know um luckily i think again my
family my parents
ingrained that into me enough uh
that i've never been afraid to put that
work in
and and be the last person on set and
you know
even as a director when i can get away
with it i'll help put stuff away certain
job you know union
issues you can't do that but um
if i am in that situation where i can i
do now go why is the director carrying c
stands like because we're all in this
together
you know what i mean um obviously it
doesn't get to work out that way every
time but when it does i was overseas
doing a project and
they didn't have the same rules so i was
there loading trucks with all of them
you know um
and trying not to get in the way because
sometimes you can get in their way you
know like
and now i'm making us go slower because
i don't know what i'm doing but uh
you know when it when it's appropriate
then i try and help out whenever i can
and i love your website in that you you
not only have great photos of you on set
and things like that
but you you say here's who i've worked
with here's what i do
and you really like break it down and i
was very impressed with how you did it
and you did you do it in a fun way where
it's not it's not like you're
it's over the top you know i i was very
impressed with that i don't think i've
seen that before
thank you a lot of that credit needs to
go to actually my cousin
uh jeremy dunn who helped me build that
website
um and he's really great with that stuff
and and uh
and i felt so just humbled that the the
actors that i worked with they gave such
great quotes i was like oh my gosh i
don't know if i deserve this but
they really were helpful in that way and
and
i really really appreciated them
putting the time into even putting some
of those responses and
but yeah it was always the goal to kind
of just make it presentable and like
here's
here's what i do and and uh
um uh you know obviously the goal is to
make
myself hirable you know and and uh
and kind of showcase some of the things
that i
you know hopefully help me stand apart
uh maybe from the pack
um with with my experiences from from
the action side of things to the visual
effects side of things
and i think that's also an important
thing to think about for any aspiring
filmmakers is
is you know figuring out what you can do
that
helps you stand apart or
makes you at least unique in some
certain way
because those little things can help
you know can help you maybe edge
edge out the competition for uh i've
certainly had it where
um not only the action side of things
have helped get me jobs but also the
visual effects side
and the combination of both sometimes
has helped me
um because you know i'll get hey
you know we want you to direct this
because we know you're also
really good at action i've gotten that
call a bunch of times where
instead of just hiring a director who
maybe doesn't have that experience it's
the combination of those experiences
that have helped get me the job
or like with visual effects i got a
pretty big tv series
based on my experience with visual
effects and obviously directing they
liked my directing
good that checked that box but now it's
a it's a vfx heavy show
oh my gosh he's also a vfx consultant
like wow okay that checks another box
he can work directly with the visual
effects artists
and make sure that they're shooting it
correctly and so that helps
just edge me out so having those skills
um
and for those things are what helps me
in a lot of situations
um to maybe get hired for a job but it
could be many
you know a variety of of tool sets that
you have
um but it's it's i think important to
uh you know lean into those things and
try and
present those things let make sure
people know that you can do those things
like
you know if you're uh
you know somebody who's amazing with
horses or whatever that could actually
be a big skill i could help you direct a
movie about rodeos or you know what i
mean like
so all those things are are kind of
important to help
you stand out for for what you do you
know what i mean
and without of course naming names what
was one of the worst grunt jobs you ever
had and how did you get through it
because i get the sense that you try to
take a positive spin
with everything even if it's not
positive and i admire that
um maybe just one that was so unbearable
but somehow you got through it and i
don't know if you
took something with you in terms of
learning something or yeah
always yeah always always learning i
think
i mean i guess the grip work is it's a
lot of physical work so that was
tough but uh it wasn't like
i didn't feel bad you know during the
experience so that's tough to say that i
i had a great time but um
there's been a there was a job where i
was a
second a.d and just the conditions were
so tough
i think that was the like below freezing
temperatures and then blazing hot in the
day we're out in the middle of the
mojave desert
so and i was asked to be the first a.d
on it
but i kind of got
i don't know how to say it exactly but i
just got a bad feeling
about the project so i tried actually
not to do it
but i had some some other friends who
really wanted the job like want needed
the work
and by me turning it down then i
wouldn't be able to get all of them on
to the project
so i said look i'm not going to be the
first ad because
uh i just i smell a disaster coming
basically
and i said look i will help you i said
why don't you to one of my friends i
said how about you be the first ad i'll
be your second
and you know i'll help you with whatever
you need help with
[Music]
if you want to do it i said but i'm
warning you right now that we probably
shouldn't do this
and uh it just had to do with the people
involved and and
lack of experience and the extreme
conditions we were going to be in
so i knew that it was going to be
difficult in a way that shouldn't be
difficult you know
and that's like in the way of like
making sure people are taken care of
and all that and sure enough we trying
to survive
the the desert in that time that we were
in the below freezing temperatures and
um not having adequate uh
things like warming tents and stuff like
that to keep cast
number one warm and we did end up some
people
ended up getting hypothermia and yeah it
was bad it was bad
um but uh we made it through it so
um but yeah there was uh that was a very
very interesting experience and of
course i learned a ton
from that experience i learned uh
chief among them that you know what to
accept and not accept
um because we said yes to certain things
that we should not have said yes to
because it ended up being
um uh dangerous you know like
physically dangerous for some for for
certain things so
um but but again i don't regret the
experience because again
uh what i learned from it really really
helped me literally on
i think it was two projects later i'm
like nope here's the life experience i
now have from this this is why i won't
do this
and this is why i think you guys
shouldn't do this and they actually
listen to me
they go okay all right fair enough you
know so it was actually became a tool
for myself on on another project
of having that experience and going
look we had two actresses that got
hypothermia do you want it
oh no we don't okay well then this is
what i think you should do here's the
steps i think
that we didn't take on this project that
i think should have been taken
and so by doing that i had that
experience to draw from and if the
actresses were fine they
they recovered and everything but um
but uh yeah it was that was a difficult
one to get through
probably the most
probably the most and i guess as a
second idea i don't know if that's
really considered a grunt
job but um that was the most difficult
one i think
you